j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
consacré au retour de Bachar el-Assad
sur la scène internationale celui que
l'on surnomme le boucher de Damas
profite des conséquences du séisme qui a
frappé son peuple pour renouer des
contacts dans la région y a-t-il une
diplomatie du séisme pourquoi l'Egypte
la Turquie l'Arabie Saoudite s'était
hier revienne en Syrie que peut faire la
France avant dans des battre en expose
la stratégie du dictateur avec Samia de
chien
cette poignée de mains c'est la revanche
d'un paria hier Bachar al-Assad a reçu
le chef de la diplomatie saoudienne à
Damas aucun dirigeant de la monarchie
n'avait mis les pieds en Syrie depuis
2012 un mois plus tôt Bachar el-Assad
était lui-même reçu par le président
d'un autre pays du Golfe les Émirats
arabes unis isolés sur la scène
internationale depuis le déclenchement
de la guerre en 2011 le dirigeant syrien
ne boude pas son plaisir de renouer des
relations avec certains pays arabes un
rapprochement favorisé par le séisme qui
a touché le pays en février dernier le
séisme a profité au régime comme
euh euh euh euh euh euh euh euh euh euh
réclamez l'aide internationale aussi les
pays qui voulaient avec le régime qui
n'osait pas le après ils ont trouvé
aussi dans le séisme que c'est
l'opportunité pour renouer avec le
régime
de la vie de plusieurs observateurs
l'aide internationales auraient été
largement détournée par le régime ce
séisme a fait plus de 50 000 morts en
Syrie et en Turquie le voisin turc c'est
l'ennemi juré de Damas qui soutient une
partie des rebelles origines mais là
aussi les relations semblent se
normaliser
récepté hyperdoane n'exclut pas une
rencontre avec Bachar al-Assad car le
retour des 4 millions de réfugiés
syriens est au cœur de l'élection
présidentielle du 14 mai prochain en
Turquie
a fait le pas verbe
essentiellement pour des raisons
électoralistes dans son sens que
l'opposition dit affiche dans son
programme la volonté de renouer avec
machin lassan et de dire que bon parce
que erdoğan a rompu avec le régime
syrien on se retrouve avec des des
millions de réfugiés etc c'est vraiment
une histoire de politique intérieure
turque les Européens quant à eux sont
divisés sur l'attitude à adopter face à
Bachar al-Assad d'un côté les partisans
de la fermeté incarnés par l'Allemagne
et la France de l'autre des pays de
l'est et du Sud comme l'Italie ou la
Grèce souhaite renouer le dialogue avec
Damas
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce second débat il y a de
ma jet bonjour bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes politologue spécialiste de la Syrie
professeur à l'Université Américaine de
Paris et auteur de ces deux livres dans
la tête de Bachar el-Assad aux éditions
Actes Sud et puis chez le même éditeur
Cyril la révolution orpheline Armel
charrier bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
éditoris international à la France 24
spécialiste en géopolitique stratégie et
défense David Rigoulet rose bonsoir
bienvenue à vous chercheur à l'Institut
français d'analyse stratégique et
chercheurs associés à l'Iris vous êtes
également rédacteur en chef de la revue
Orient stratégie qu'on est également
duplex avec Samuel foret qui
correspondant de libération à Jérusalem
bonsoir à vous auteur de ce livre les
aurores incertaine aux éditions grassées
retour sur les révolutions arabes dans
lequel il y a plusieurs chapitres qui
sont consacrés à la scierie bienvenue à
vous et Mathieu croissanto évidemment
est resté à mes côtés le séisme du 6
février qui a rajouté une épreuve faut
d'abord commencer par dire ça
supplémentaire à celle subi depuis 12
ans par le peuple syrien est-ce que il
faut dire que c'est en train de profiter
à Bachar el-Assad oui on peut dire que
c'est en train de profiter à Bachar
el-Assad à savoir que la population qui
a été surtout frappée par ce séisme
c'est la même population que Bachar
el-Assad lui-même avait déplacé en
partie vers la région de hedleyb qu'il
avait bombardé dans le nord vers le
nord-ouest qu'il avait bombardé pendant
des années que lui et son allié russe
avait détruit toute l'infrastructure
sanitaire hôpitaux dispensaire dans
cette même région et les ondes que
contrôle le régime ont été beaucoup
moins impactés par le séisme sauf que
certains acteurs de la région surtout
certains acteurs arabes on considéré que
ça s'est peut-être le moment pour faire
un geste ou pour normaliser avec le
régime syrien en utilisant également
d'autres contextes ou prétexte comme
celui de la présence la mienne la
présence turque et l'absence de présence
arabe qu'il faut modifier rectifier
après 12 ans de conflits donc il y a
plusieurs enjeux mais certes la question
du séisme a profité au régime et on y
reviendra évidemment en détail à Armelle
charrier est-ce que vous employez cette
cette expression j'ai dans que j'ai
utilisé l'ail dans les titres la
diplomatie du séisme est-ce que vous
parlez de ça aussi
non moi j'utilise pas mais je comprends
ce qui a d'intéressant dans la
diplomatie du séisme parce que ça
raconte un fait qui est inattendu et qui
fait qu'à un moment donné du coup vous
avez un rapprochement par contre je
pense que il y avait beaucoup
d'opportunités et que du coup ce séisme
a profité en fait et que derrière il y
avait certainement une réflexion qui
était menée par un ensemble de pays dont
on va parler avec l'Arabie saoudite à sa
tête qui est de se dire que il faut que
elle arrive à avoir un moyen orient
prospère c'est vraiment sa vision de se
dire comment est-ce qu'on recrée un
Moyen-Orient et que recréer un
Moyen-Orient ce qui complètement surpris
tout le monde avec cette signature d'un
accord entre la rouille Saoudite et
l'Iran ça passait évidemment par le fait
de s'entendre avec un certain nombre de
pays donc quand il y a eu en fait
l'histoire du séisme il y a eu
certainement beaucoup d'opportunités et
d'histoire elle est aussi faite
opportunisme voilà et de se dire
finalement si on vient à aider on aidera
doublement parce que d'abord ça veut
dire que on est visible la population
elle nous voit et donc on arrive en tant
que frère arabe on est là pour aider or
c'est quand même des pays qui ont connu
en Syrie il y a eu effectivement un
fracas mais tout le monde s'y aimait et
ça vous dit aussi s'ils sont mais dans
ce fracas et non seulement ils vont
venir mais en même temps ils montrent
aussi que ils font différemment des
Occidentaux et on commence à entendre
finalement toute l'histoire qu'on va
découvrir où on dit bah vous regardez
les Occidentaux et vous font encore
payer des sanctions internationales et
nous on passe dans un autre âge David
Riboulet rose qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il faut peut-être le rappeler depuis le
séisme du du 6 février à quel
rapprochement on a on a assisté on je
vous demande pas de faire la liste des
pays mais il y a quand même voilà un
ballet diplomatique à Damas d'abord par
rapport au séisme il y a pour la
première fois un avion saoudien c'est
posé sur les aéroport d'Alep c'est la
première fois depuis 2011 pour apporter
de l'aide d'une aide humanitaire dans la
région sous contrôle du gouvernement de
Damas et non pas justement d'autres
régions donc c'était un indicateur que
ceux qui ont évoqué la diplomatie
effectivement du séisme il y avait un
accélérateur effectivement une séquence
qui qui s'ouvrait mais qui avait été
préparée quand même puisque il faut
rappeler que les Émirats arabes unis par
exemple ont annoncé la réouverture fin
de décembre 2018 a suivi par le barème
d'ailleurs donc il y avait l'esquisse
d'une normalisation il y avait un
lobbying d'ailleurs des émirats qui
n'ont pas été un acteur affirmé de
soutien à la résistance aux insurgés
comme mon pullet le Qatar et l'Arabie
Saoudite donc une position plus facile
pour les émiratis qui ont une vision
stratégique de la région effectivement
avec l'idée de réintégrer la série
Bachir al-Assad en actant le fait qu'il
va rester au pouvoir que ça c'est acté
dans la tête des dirigeants régionaux et
que le principe de réalité quoi on est
toujours là et donc il restera on parle
du chemin de Damas
c'est une conversion non pas par fidés
mais une conversion par pragmatisme on
va dire effectivement c'est le sens des
réalités et l'idée justement à partir du
moment où il faut le réintégrer entre
guillemets ça passe par un certain
nombre de conditions implicite plus ou
moins implicite notamment en insistant
sur son arabilité pour tenter de
l'éloigner un petit peu de l'Iran qui a
une empreinte évidemment très forte en
Syrie et qui donc qui est son allié
depuis le début a sauvé évidemment le
régime de Bachar el-Assad avec la Russie
donc il y a tout un jeu qui se met en
place et qui est aussi un effet
collatéral on va dire induit de l'accord
du 10 mars entre Riyad et Téhéran parce
que là il y a une reconfiguration
régionale très importante et qui
marginalise des FA les Occidentaux et
c'est pour ça que ce débat est
passionnant Mathieu sur le séisme parce
que j'ai lu que même l'aide humanitaire
avait été détournée de son objectif par
le régime
juste pour clarifier par exemple la
ville d'Alep et les régions ou la
campagne autour d'Alep où il y a eu
effectivement une aide saoudienne qui
est arrivé la population là-bas a déjà
été déportée et les habitations sont
presque vides c'est pour ça qu'il y a
pas eu beaucoup de victimes dans ces
ondes là contrôlé par par le régime
après il y a des photos des parfois des
rumeurs et parfois des informations
documentées sur le fait que des hommes
d'affaires proches du régime profitent
de l'aide humanitaire et ils vendent
cette aide sur les marchés syriens il
parfois arrive même à l'exporter donc il
y a pas mal de d'informations sur ce
sujet et ce n'est pas nouveau c'est
historique même il y a des enquêtes et
des soupçons de corruption au sein de
certaines agences on nous viennent
toujours présente à Damas qui n'ont pas
quitté Damas il y a eu même des
démissions etc donc la question de la
corruption elle est au coeur évidemment
de système et les Syriens et les
céréales connaissent cela c'est plutôt
encore une fois du côté de edelweb ou
les victimes étaient plus nombreuses et
dans des situations beaucoup plus
vulnérables bien avant le séisme donc
vous nous parlez les nouvelles ère
diplomatique d'un nouvel équilibre qui
est en train de naître au Moyen-Orient
qui avait commencé on l'a bien compris
avant le séisme et qui s'accélère depuis
ce tremblement de terre Samuel forêt
vous êtes dans votre livre voilà revenu
sur les révolutions arabes est-ce que
vous diriez là avec la séquence que l'on
vit c'est presque la fin d'un cycle
effectivement bon à la fois on revient
aussi dans une certaine forme de
continuité la constante du régime Massal
que ce soit à ça de faire appel et
Bachar el-Assad c'est de jouer sur une
capacité de nuisance ça fait plus de 10
ans que les pays de qui entourent de la
région donc l'Arabie Saoudite et aussi
la Jordanie la Turquie etc on est des
gros problèmes à régler avec la série et
tout le monde s'aperçoit que Bachar
el-Assad a réussi à se maintenir et va
s'en maintenir donc il y avait il y
avait cette idée de randonnée il faut
arriver à essayer de régler des des
problèmes pendant après il y a il faut
arriver à le séisme et apparu comme une
forme d'opportunité pour de nombreux
pays
et pour essayer justement d'avancer sur
le plan des relations diplomatiques pour
essayer de de régler quelques problèmes
diplomatiques après avec le César actes
qui a été voté par les États-Unis donc
en 2020 mais 500 mots
ça va être difficile de rétablir des
relations économiques fortes avec la
série sans son donc c'est pour l'instant
ça reste un des une politique de premier
pas la Jordanie a
réengagé
un dialogue très prudent donc avec avec
la Syrie donc c'est une politique des
premiers pas l'Arabie Saoudite veut
prendre une forme de leadership sur ce
sujet
voilà on verra ce que ça va donner ce
que ça va donner dans les dans les mois
à venir notamment le 19 mai lors de la
de la prochaine réunion de la dégrade
évidemment la Liga on en reparle tout à
l'heure un mot peut-être de ces
sanctions elles ont été suspendues dans
la foulée du séisme qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé sur les sanctions internationales
vis-à-vis de la Syrie oh elle subissent
de toute manière sur internationale
parce que après c'est des personnes qui
sont stigmatisées par les sanctions
internationales que ce soit Bachar
al-Assad que ce soit sa famille etc ça
fait partie quand même des choses qui
ont un coup ensuite évidemment les
rapports par rapport à la population
sont là et même pour des organismes par
exemple qui sont européens qui sont
français ou les choses comme ça il y a
eu une demande d'aide donc l'aide a été
apportée mais elle était beaucoup plus
compliquée et par exemple les organismes
qui étaient intervenus par exemple dans
le cadre du Liban ont expliqué que
autant quand il y avait eu ces
explosions Liban et tu avais pu
intervenir très vite autant lorsqu'il
fallait qu'ils interviennent en Syrie
les demandes étaient étudiées c'était
beaucoup plus complexes justement pour
les questions de corruption et donc
beaucoup plus difficile d'arriver
jusqu'au population alors
deux choses par rapport à votre question
sur une fin de cycle les Émirats arabes
unis mènent une contre-offensive ou ce
qu'on a appelé une contre-révolution
dans toute la région depuis 2013 donc ce
n'est pas si vous voulez un peu
surprenant de voir leur repositionnement
aujourd'hui ils n'ont jamais d'ailleurs
fermé leur consulat à Damas le Bahreïn
n'a jamais fermé son ambassade il n'est
pas véritablement de retour il était
déjà présent et l'enjeu pour les Emirats
et surtout cette stratégie c'était de
montrer que le statut quo le retour au
régime au business azur c'est mieux que
ces bouleversements qui ne finissent pas
et qui déstabilise toute la région
c'était ça l'argument en plus dans le
caseria il y a l'Iran et la Turquie ils
veulent être également présent pour la
suite mais par rapport à la question des
sanctions et du César Act qui bloque ou
frêne disons certaines normalisations
maintenant il y a un nouvel acte qui
vient d'être qui qui est passé qui est
le cap d'Agon actes parce que alors
parmi les les
on va en parler un peu plus tard sur
l'Arabie Saoudite si vous voulez bien
aujourd'hui surtout un Arco état mené
par la force
passionnant effectivement le captagon en
fait amine produit à bas prix produit en
Syrie on va vraiment en parler ensemble
mais je voudrais quand même rappeler
quelques chiffres qui sont terribles
pourquoi et qui expliquent pour qu'on
surnomme Bachar el-Assad le boucher de
Damas plus de 300000 civils tués depuis
le début de la guerre en Syrie 6
millions 600 000 réfugiés syriens dans
le monde Mathieu la justice française
elle s'est dit s'écrits on va y venir
mais d'abord peut-être un mot des
relations diplomatiques entre la France
et la Syrie on avait toujours au point
mort oui même si depuis quelques
semaines real politique oblige on entend
que certains réfléchissent en haut lieu
au moyen éventuels de reprendre langue
avec Bachar el-Assad en tout cas avec
son régime sans s'affaiblir ni le
renforcer donc vous n'imaginez que c'est
quand même assez compliqué parce qu'on
rappelle que il y a plus de relations
diplomatiques entre les deux pays que la
France a rappelé son ambassadeur dès
2012 et qu'officiellement Paris n'a pas
changé de doctrine et s'en tient
toujours à la fameuse recherche d'une
solution politique sur les bases des
conférences de Genève auquel plus
personne ne croit et qui n'ont qui n'ont
rien donné mais en tout cas ça reste ça
reste la ligne même si on se souvient
aussi de de la petite phrase d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2021 au moment de la chute de
daesh qui avait dit bah il faudra parler
à Bachar et assez représentants parce
qu'il disait mon ennemi c'est daech et
il faudra finir par parler à Bacha mais
pour l'instant rien de concret et il y a
une décision vous venez vous venez en
parler au début de ce mois d'avril qui
ne devrait rien arranger et donc on
parle d'une décision judiciaire oui
parce que le 4 avril dernier de juge
d'instruction ont donné le renvoi devant
la justice française de trois hauts
responsables du régime syrien de
bacharlassad pour la mort de deux
citoyens franco-cyriens alors il y a un
procès qui va se tenir contre alimam
look Djamila San et Abdel Salam Mahmoud
trois figures des services de
renseignement syriens qui vont être
envoyés aux assises pour complicité de
crimes contre l'humanité et même des
lits de guerre alors c'est un procès qui
est né d'une tragédie comme il y en a eu
beaucoup beaucoup en Syrie on le sait
celle de Mazen dabag et de son fils
Patrick de Franco syrien ont été arrêtés
en 2013 par des officiers déclarants qui
travaillaient pour les services de
renseignement de l'armée de l'air ils
ont été transférés à la triste
célèbre prison d'almeidir dénoncé comme
un centre de torture du régime et c'est
évidemment là qu'ils sont morts mais
cette décision c'est une première
victoire symbolique parce que ils sont
visés par des mandats internationaux ils
seront pas sur le banc des accusés ces
trois responsables mais c'est quand même
une victoire quand même pour la famille
des victimes comme pour les actions
défense des droits de l'homme qui ont
beaucoup pleuré pour rendre ces
poursuites possibles est-ce que ce sera
le premier procès en France concernant
c'est le premier procès en France qui
concerne la série c'est un grand facteur
d'espoir pour des centaines de milliers
de victimes syriennes qui attendent que
justice soit rendue on peut préciser que
chez nos voisins allemands il y a aussi
beaucoup de plaintes de Syriens réfugiés
dans ce pays qui qui se sont multipliés
il y a un dernier candidate c'est celui
d'un médecin des hôpitaux militaires
syriens qui va être jugé Francfort enfin
jugé à Francfort pardon pour crime
contre l'humanité lui aussi il doit
répondre de plusieurs cas de
18-4 tortures au moins avéré d'opposants
et du meurtre d'un détenu David rigoloz
est-ce que vous croyez qu'on jugera un
jour Bachar el-Assad ce qui peut sembler
paradoxal de dire ça alors qu'on est en
train de parler d'une sorte de
rentabilité diplomatique je vous dirais
ce qu'on jugera un jour Vladimir Poutine
et voilà une question qu'on a déjà posée
sur ce plateau à laquelle il n'est pas
facile de répondre je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est pour ça c'est c'est dans
l'absolu non ce qui ce qui a changé par
rapport probablement à il y a une
plusieurs décennies c'est qu'il y a plus
la culture de l'impunité formelle
c'est-à-dire il était l'idée qu'il y
avait une immunité de toute façon
irréversible ne tient plus c'est-à-dire
que il y a peu de chances qu'il soit un
jour jugé ça vaut pour lui comme
Vladimir Poutine qui est effectivement
il y a un mandat d'arrêt mais en
revanche en termes effectivement
visuel en terme de de publicitaire c'est
pas du tout comme avant il y a une
impossibilité d'ailleurs de se déplacer
comme aurait pu le faire d'autres
dictateurs d'autres temps on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec au Soudan avec le homard
déchire qui qui choisissent qui
sélectionnait bien les pays où il se
déplaçaient parce que quand même on sait
jamais voilà donc il y a cette impunité
qui pouvait prévaloir très très
largement avant et de ce point de vue là
c'est quand même un progrès évidemment
au regard des souffrances qui ont été
qui ont été faites c'est ça peut
paraître dérisoire mais ça ne l'est pas
c'est il faut quand même dans ce débat
pas faire comme si comme si de rien
n'était et comme si effectivement la
réhabilitation de Bachar el-asset
coulait coulait couler de source c'est
ce que vous attendez des pays
occidentaux de ne pas laisser faire
finalement ne pas laisser dérouler ce
tapis rouge en fait peut-être il y a
deux niveaux par rapport à cette
question même au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle réalisme politique aujourd'hui
Bachar el-Assad il y a aucun intérêt à
normaliser avec son régime c'est un
régime qui tient grâce à deux
occupations étrangères du pays qui sont
l'occupation russe et l'occupation
iranienne avec des milices avec un état
incapable de payer des salaires qui
laissent les ministres d'ailleurs
elle-même s'autofinancer sur le terrain
en imposant des des impôts en volant en
payant et
sa source ça ça source principale
aujourd'hui de revenus est relié à tout
ce qui est drogue et tout ce qui est
captagon et autres qu'il exportent vers
les pays du Golfe via la Jordanie et
vers l'Europe d'où l'intérêt jordanien
aussi et même saoudien ça a été évoqué
officiellement dans les négociations
d'arrêter les l'importation de de ces
produits et puis d'un point de vue
juridique qui donne aussi des dimensions
politiques on envoie aussi rien et aux
syriennes un message si jamais on
normalise avec Assad qui ne sont pas
protégés par le droit international que
leur vie et leur dignité ne sont pas
pour nous des priorités on peut faire
avec un régime qui est responsable de la
mort d'un million de Syriens qui a
déporté et a déplacé des millions à
l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur qui
garde toujours 100000 prisonniers
politiques qui sont torturés on a des
preuves de la mort de 30 000 prisonniers
politiques ou détenu sous la torture et
les exécutions la famine etc Il a affamé
sa population il l'a gazé on n'a pas vu
ça depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale il
y a eu énormément de crimes
malheureusement il y a eu des génocides
et tout mais si vous voulez tous ces
outils de violence et cette barbarie qui
s'est battue sur le peuple syrien et les
rares et si on normalise malgré tout
cela avec le régime on envoie un message
que vous êtes abandonné et ce message là
politiquement parlant est très dangereux
parce que c'est ça qui nourrit le
nihilisme la haine du monde le sentiment
d'abandon qui est et qui joue en faveur
de certains groupes qui profitent qui
recrutent en disant voyez nous sommes
dans des saveurs de démocraties
occidentales c'est ce que d'accord
aujourd'hui que la série est mis au banc
de la communauté internationale parce
que si on sait qu'elle a réussi si
aujourd'hui le monde arabe si je sais
pas quels sont les relations précises
avec la Chine est-ce qu'en fait il a pas
mis au banc de la communauté
occidentale simplement et pas
internationale
pour varier un peu les distribuer la
parole non mais je pense que vous avez
raison c'est tout d'ailleurs et je vous
ai écouté c'est d'ailleurs tout le
problème que l'on a c'est que est-ce
qu'elle est le poids que l'on représente
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui quand on
repart du côté de l'occident il y a
cette vision qui reste une vision qui
est de des droits de l'homme qui va
parler de la population qui est déplacée
qui va parler de la corruption qui va
parler des heures qui ont été commis etc
et puis vous avez le reste du monde qui
commence à peser lourd qui commence à
penser différemment et c'est vrai que
lorsque l'on pensait à la Syrie on avait
en tête la Russie et on avait en tête
l'Iran mais l'Iran c'est classique on
est dans un arc chiite et la Russie
jouait effectivement aussi une guerre
qu'on comprenait sur ce territoire là
parce qu'elle avait ses intérêts avec le
port Méditerranée et parce que elle
avait aussi d'autres intérêts dans le
pays lorsque l'on regarde sur le monde
arabe on est sur encore autre chose et
c'est là la difficulté c'est est-ce que
on va être les seuls à pouvoir dire
regarder il ne faut pas le remettre en
notabilité je suis d'accord sur le fond
mais un moment donné la Ligue arabe va
dire on est d'accord pour réintégrer la
Syrie dans la Ligue arabe c'est-à-dire
des pays du Golfe l'Arabie saoudite le
Qatar qui est contre mais qui dans ces
cas-là elle accepterait des pays qui
sont invités qui pèsent aussi lourd que
l'Egypte ou d'autres pays qui sont là et
à partir du moment donné où le pape est
franchement on est on rentre dans une
autre dimension et ce qui nous surprend
encore plus c'est que si on rentre dans
cette vision de notabilisation par les
pays arabes on est sur un arc ce qui a
un axe sunnite shit qu'on a encore
jamais vu et qui va effectivement peser
alors on ne sait pas si ça va prendre
lieu on sait pas combien de temps ça va
durer mais pour nous en tout cas qui
sommes européens ça pose des vraies
questions alors vous parliez de de
celles et ceux c'est syriens qui se
battent pour leur liberté qui se sentent
aujourd'hui abandonnés je vous propose
deux témoignages recueillis notamment
lors des manifestations qui ont qui
marquait le 12e anniversaire du début de
l'insurrection regardez
nous avons participé au début de la
révolution en 2011 et nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui car nos revendications sont
toujours les mêmes 12 ans après nous
voulons faire connaître au monde entier
l'oppression à laquelle nous avons été
confrontés de la détention jusqu'au
déplacement en passant par les
assassinats nous ne reculerons pas nous
ne permettrons aucun politicien de ce
monde quel que soit ses efforts pour
normaliser ses liens avec le régime de
Bachar el-Assad de nous forcer à
abandonner nos revendications autre
témoignage tout de suite vous évoquiez
la Ligue arabe justement c'est une
habitante du nord de la Syrie on écoute
nous les habitants du nord de la Syrie
nous nous sentons trahis lorsque nous
entendons parler de la normalisation
avec Assad comment se fait-il qu'après
12 ans de lutte et de révolution ils
viennent aujourd'hui lui dire voici de
nouveau ton siège à la ligarable c'est
inacceptable
David on ne n'y pas encore tout à fait
il n'a pas encore n'a pas de nouveau son
siège à la Liga de toute façon pour
qu'il ait il faut lever le véto ça veut
dire parce que c'est vraiment l'Arabie
Saoudite d'abord la prochaine réunion
est prévue Ariane en Arabie Saoudite et
on sait que les il y a eu des contacts
depuis janvier notamment numéro 2 de
service de France enfin le nouveau chef
des services de renseignement généraux
au seum Lucas c'est a fait un petit
détour en fait Ariane pour discuter avec
le chef du service de renseignement
saoudien donc il y a une préparation de
quelque chose qui est dans l'air même si
les Saoudiens ne veulent pas signer un
chèque en blanc et on va retrouver la
question du captagon
qui est une donnée centrale qui est
souvent en creux on l'oublie mais en
fait qui est qui est central y compris
pour les Jordaniens qui ont rouvert la
frontière et c'est une hémorragie c'est
quoi c'est une question de santé
publique pour les pays du Golfe c'est
une question de santé publique c'est un
amphétamine en fait oui c'est un
amphétamine c'est qui renvoie l'ancienne
phénicilline des années 60 mais en fait
c'est c'est effectivement une
amphitielle produite massivement en
Syrie qui est la première entrée de
devise de la Syrie qui rapporte
plusieurs milliards par an à comparer au
120 millions d'exportation de l'huile de
l'huile d'olive donc ça donne une idée
quand même effectivement et on sait que
bah ça peut pas être fait sans une
supervision d'un certain nombre de
responsables et dans les négociations
notamment avec les Saoudiens c'est un
élément déterminant parce que il y a
effectivement comme vous dites un
problème de santé publique en terme
cardiaque en termes etc c'est ce qu'on
appelle ce sont les petites pilules de
demi-lune comme on les appelle
[Musique]
la série l'Arabie Saoudite avait pris
une position assez ferme et depuis 2015
militairement parlant les Saoudiens n'en
voit plus d'aide à l'opposition syrienne
il se focalise sur leur guerre au Yaman
et ils sont plus dans le momentum de la
guerre en Syrie par contre ils avaient
de conditions la première c'est que
Bachar el-Assad doit soit affaiblir soit
demander aux Iraniens de partir or
évidemment Bachar el-Assad n'est pas du
tout ni dans cette capacité ni il
souhaite le faire la deuxième c'était la
question de la drogue et du Cap d'Agon
maintenant après la réconciliation avec
l'Iran il y a une nouvelle dans la
région celle d'un d'un équilibre disons
la Chine essaye de jouer un rôle
l'absence des Américains permet aux
Chinois de progresser un peu mais moi je
ne dirais pas que les Occidentaux
perdent leur poids dans la région
puisque ce qui a freiné pendant toutes
ces années la plupart des États dans le
monde de normaliser avec Assad c'est la
position occidentale même la question de
la reconstruction pourquoi la Chine n'a
pas déjà investi des milliards de
dollars pour reconstruire pourquoi les
Émirats Arabes Unis ne l'ont pas fait
pourquoi les Saoudiens n'ont pas essayé
de se réconcilier avec le régime avant
parce que il y a une position
occidentale donc la position occidentale
même dans un monde qui change un peu qui
on voit il y a des des États qui
s'imposent de plus en plus dans
certaines régions quand le monde
occidental prend une position il peut
faire la différence ça c'est de 1 de 2
pour la Ligue arabe juste il faut dire
que il faut un consensus pour le moment
il y a le Qatar et le Maroc qui
s'opposent au retour de Bachar el-Assad
cela évidemment peut être négocié il
peut y avoir d'autres conditions mais
moi je pense que on est trop optimiste
quand on parle d'une réconciliation qui
change la configuration dans la région
moi je suis parmi ceux qui disent que
les relations entre l'Arabie et l'Iran
ne vont pas être dans une lune de miel
ou une dynamique positive pendant très
longtemps les Iraniens sont pragmatiques
oui mais ils ne sacrifieront pas ni leur
contrôle en Irak ni au Liban ni en Syrie
cela ne peut pas être toléré par
l'Arabie donc c'est une phase et si on
tombe dans le piège de cette phase c'est
qu'on et ça a été malheureusement à
plusieurs reprises fait en Occident on
se précipite un peu plus rapidement
qu'il le faut et on ne comprend pas la
sociologie politique et les enjeux de la
région on y reviendra là-dessus mais je
voudrais il y a forcément un pays qui
regarde ça de très près peut-être avec
inquiétude cette Israël ça me le ferait
comment comment Israël justement analyse
et réagit à cette nouvelle donne
Israël voit en fait d'une certaine
manière et ils aimeraient de raison on
paye en quelque sorte les factures de
2013 non seulement avec le Émirats
arabes unis qui seraient engage qui
serait engage
effectivement la contre-révolution
mais aussi le désengagement des
États-Unis et le choix de Barack Obama
de ne pas frapper la série après les
après les attaques chimiques dans la
route donc on est toujours dans
seulement dans ce moment là mais en même
temps les États-Unis et aussi la France
sont toujours présents en Syrie ils sont
présents dans le Nord stp je le rappelle
dans la zone du Kurdistan syrien donc
ils ont quand même toujours un oeil sur
ce pays à un œil sur cette région et ils
peuvent profiter de cette position là
pour l'instant elle se croisait discret
mais ils sont quand même réellement là
Israël voilà situation comme une forme
de de distanciation pas forcément
distanciation des États-Unis et de
l'Occident par rapport donc rien et donc
une forme de réajustement
régional donc après ce retrait qui est
progressif et finalement de de retour
presque à une forme de situation
où on était
avant avant 2011 avant la Révolution les
révolutions
avec un live relativement inquiet très
prudent mais effectivement je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus se dire qu'il va
y avoir un bouleversement
pour rappel on a un cas concret les le
régime syrien a négocier avec les Kurdes
un accord pour en octobre 2019 pour que
pour que la région du creux d'essence
aérien revienne sous le sous-sol
et aujourd'hui encore ça fait 4 ans
après ce n'est pas encore le cas donc
vous allez comment les événements se
développent et se remettre en place
alors justement on va parler tout de
suite du Kurdistan syrien grâce à
Quentin calmé bon rebonsoir Quentin
puisque trois parlementaires ce sont
rendus dans ce Kurdistan syrien dans le
nord du pays exactement c'est la visite
la plus récente de parlementaire
français dans la région les
parlementaires ne se rendent plus à
Damas Bachar al-Assad des personnages
non grata mais on voit certains députés
sénateurs qui entretiennent toujours des
relations avec les Kurdes on le sait qui
sont coincés entre la Turquie la Syrie
l'Irak et l'Iran de sénateurs
communistes et une députée écologiste
était au Kurdistan syrien au nord du
pays une zone très enclavée du pays on
va voir certaines photos de leur visite
et qui n'est pas sous domination de
Bachar el-Assad une zone dans une
situation humanitaire compliquée depuis
la guerre avec l'État islamique la zone
est aussi difficile d'accès aussi pour
les humanitaires depuis le tremblement
de terre elle souffre aussi de l'embargo
qui vise la série bien qu'elle soit
administrée par une autorité autonome en
rentrant de ce voyage les sénateurs et
communistes et députés écologistes ont
fait un communiqué je voulais vous lire
un extrait le régime deshumanisant de
Bachar el-Assad tente de saisir
l'opportunité du séisme pour se
repositionner et retrouver une
légitimité il profite de l'indifférence
internationale pour faire porter la
responsabilité exclusive de la situation
aux sanctions occidentales et exigent
une normalisation politique les
parlementaires qui ont d'ailleurs pu
rencontrer les représentants de
l'administration locale on les a vu tout
à l'heure sur les photos ils étaient
invités d'ailleurs par la NES
l'administration autonome du Nord et de
l'Est de la Syrie l'idée était d'évoquer
la reconstruction de cette partie du
pays alors justement les sénateurs ont
effectué cette visite auprès des
autorités locales coincées entre le
gouvernement Damas et la pression de la
Turquie et aussi pour qu'il puisse
reconnaître gagner une reconnaissance à
l'échelle internationale écoutez Pierre
Laurent il
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
du poids des pays occidentaux dans la
région Armelle charrier parce que je
vois point finalement dans les
différentes interventions est-ce que oui
ou non c'est une nouvelle ère qui
commence dans laquelle les pays
occidentaux vont peser de moins en moins
ce que vous dites ça on n'en sait rien
je pense qu'on est en train de parler
évidemment de choses qui sont en ce
moment sur les sables mouvants mais ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut détecter ce
sont les intentions à défaut d'avoir
aujourd'hui réellement les actes et
c'est ça en fait qui parlant on voit
clairement que depuis la guerre en
Ukraine il y a aujourd'hui un flottement
du monde qui a envie de fonctionner en
dehors de l'Occident et l'Occident c'est
les États-Unis et l'Europe ça on le
constate du coup dans le cadre en fait
du Moyen-Orient on a une accélération on
a vu l'Arabie saoudite à un moment donné
prendre parole avec la Chine elle
prenait parole avec la Chine sur les
questions de vente du pétrole et
accepter de vendre son pétrole avec une
monnaie qui se la monnaie du van c'est à
dire de sortir en fait des questions du
dollar parce qu'elle voulait sortir de
ces questions là et on voit petit à
petit tout cela se met en place parce
que du coup il y a une logique qui est
de se dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
rester avec les Américains finalement
puisqu'ils n'ont plus besoin de nous
puisqu'ils ont eux-mêmes leur propre
pétrole puisque nous il faut qu'on
s'imagine différent ça c'est le nouveau
prince enfin qui est pas encore prince
qui le pense qui dit il faut mettre ce
moyen orient prospère voilà c'est ça et
donc il faut aller chercher une économie
en dehors de l'économie du pétrole donc
il imagine son Arabie Saoudite avec ses
villes du futur et pour ça il lui faut
du tourisme et puis il faut un
agriculturel il lui faut un attrait
d'homme d'affaires évidemment si vous
avez un monde autour qui est en guerre
ça ne marche pas donc on a vu évidemment
cette main tendue à l'Iran très
surprenante mais cette main tendue à
l'Iran parce que derrière il fallait
avoir une trêve au Yémen le Yémen c'est
à quelques inclure de l’arabie Saoudite
donc lorsque vous avez des hommes
d'affaires ou des touristes qui sont là
si vous avez une guerre juste à côté et
qu'on vous tire à missile vous n'aurez
plus votre nouvelle économie donc là on
voyait effectivement une approche et
puis on voit que s'il faut normaliser
les choses avec l'Iran comment l'Arabie
Saoudite pays s'unites qui ne s'entend
pas avec l'Iran va discuter avec l'Iran
évidemment ça nous fait tous poser une
interrogation est-ce qu'ils vont y
arriver ce serait très sois prenant mais
pourquoi pas qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tous à
gagner l'Iran a gagné le fait qu'elle a
besoin d'argent elle a besoin d'une
recomposition économique elle a besoin
de reconstruction on a échoué les
Américains n'ont pas arrivé les
Européens n'ont pas arrivé parce que ils
n'ont pas tenu peut-être leurs
engagements mais quoi qu'il en soit du
coup il y a ça la série arrive là dedans
en ayant la même politique en disant
finalement moi aussi j'ai besoin d'avoir
une reconstruction de mon pays j'ai
besoin d'avoir de l'argent qu'est-ce que
cherche l'Arabie Saoudite est-ce qu'elle
cherche à avoir un interlocuteur arabe
Bachar el-Assad est un interlocuteur
arabe qui est capable de lui ouvrir une
langue pour discuter avec les Iraniens
peut-être est-ce qu'elle cherche
effectivement que l'histoire de captagon
soit arrêtée comment son temps l'Iran
avait pointé du doigt les routes qui
arrivaient de l'Afghanistan parce que du
coup ça lui mettait toute une opiacée
qui mettait sa population à mal donc
tous ces pays ont des relations par
rapport à les uns avec les autres
évidemment c'est trop tôt pour savoir si
ça va prendre langue mais pour nous il
nous faut regarder ça avec beaucoup
d'attention parce qu'on voit des
reconfigurations qu'on aurait jamais
imaginé avec des volontés économiques et
aussi quelque part des colères c'est
indiscutable que l'Arabie Saoudite et un
certain nombre de pays autour disent
finalement les américains ils ont lâché
l'Afghanistan ils ont lâché l'Irak ça
peut donc avoir des conséquences j'ai
posé une question qui est peut-être un
peu provocatrice mais est-ce que la la
question des droits de l'homme qui qui
porte finalement cet argument qui porte
pour les démocraties occidentales parce
qu'on comprend bien que faire de la
réelle politique avec Bachar el-Assad
c'est quand même très compliqué dans une
démocratie occidentale est-ce que ces
arguments là ils pèsent pas du tout
finalement très peu ou presque pas dans
les pays arabes qui sont en train de
revenir vers la Syrie ah bah c'est pas
leur critère premier ça c'est ça c'est
clair donc de ce point de vue là il y a
pas d'ambiguïté mais pour prolonger ce
que vous disiez je pense qu'on peut
d'ores et déjà dire qu'il y a
quelques une situation qui il y a une
tectonique des plaques géopolitiques en
ce moment et que il y aura des
conséquences en termes de
marginalisation pour les occidentaux il
y a aucun doute là-dessus pour une
raison c'est Besson pas les bras quoi
c'est c'est un peu ça quoi
éventuellement mais en tout cas c'est un
fait et il y a un élément qui est qui
est assez symptomatique c'est qu'il y a
une autonomisation
stratégique des acteurs régionaux et on
l'a vu à deux reprises on l'a vu avec
l'accord qui a été signé en Chine entre
riad et Téhéran et on l'a vu avant
lorsque il y a eu la fin de nos recevoir
de Mohamed bin Salman auprès de Joe
Biden pour le cours du pétrole et le
maintien justement dans l'OPE plus d'un
niveau élevé contrairement à ce que
souhaitaient les Occidentaux et et
manifestement les Occidentaux n'ont pas
été en mesure de changer le la décision
de MBS donc ça montre bien
qu'effectivement il y a il y a
clairement à défaut d'une exclusion en
tout cas un affaiblissement des
Occidentaux et de leur prétention au
niveau régional et la France il y a de
ma jet oui alors juste de mon pas par
rapport aussi au ce qu'on considère
d'être des deux poids de mesure du côté
occidental dans la région parce que il y
a chez certains sociétés je parle pas
des régimes les régimes c'est vrai la
question des droits humains ne les
concerne pas de toute façon leurs
problèmes avec Bachar el-Assad c'était
plutôt la présence iranienne beaucoup
plus que ces crimes contre sa population
mais dans plusieurs sociétés arabes il y
a évidemment la question palestinienne
et le
la position occidentale toujours
complaisante avec Israël 2013 comme ça a
été dit était un tournant par rapport à
la série après l'attaque chimique ce qui
a montré à des acteurs locaux et
régionaux que finalement les ont
abandonné ou bien ne sont plus
très intéressés par cette région pour
les Saoudiens ils en veulent aux
Américains que Obama avait abandonné
Moubarak Ben Ali deux alliés américains
que finalement ben Salman le prince
héritier veut se montrer indépendant
avec une marche de manœuvre qui lui
permet de contacter les Chinois les
Russes de diversifier les ressources et
en même temps les relations mais ça
reste aussi un chantage fait aux
Occidentaux que sous quelle est la marge
de manœuvre des occidentaux il y a
toujours une marge de manœuvre reliée
pas seulement à aux mécanismes de
sanction il y a un poids économique il y
a un poids culturel vous savez même
l'Arabie Saoudite avec toute
l'occidentalisation c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle là-bas avec les changements
qui s'opèrent ils sont en train de
négocier avec la Chine des contrats
économiques mais ils sont aussi en train
d'imiter certaines démarches que ce soit
dans la libéralisation des mœurs ou par
rapport au fest cheval par rapport à
tout ce qui son père dans la société il
y a des repères
occidentaux qui sont là donc le poids de
l'Occident c'est aussi un soft power et
non pas seulement les muscles et le
poids historique qu'il avait et qui n'a
pas su utiliser parce qu'il a été
toujours à deux vitesses et avec
plusieurs approches merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat j'ai
rappelé les titres de vos livres ziana
jet dans la tête de Bachar el-Assad qui
est publié aux éditions Actes Sud tout
comme Cyril la révolution orpheline et
puis ça moi une forêt votre livre
également les Aurors incertaines très
beaux titres publiés aux éditions
grassais merci à tous encore une fois
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de
sciences publiques je vous dis à demain
18h22 heures et puis notez votre
prochaine invité dans la matinale
également signé reçoit François Patriot
président du groupe Renaissance au Sénat
belle soirée
[Musique]